alright ok this is different we got a
Dutch on board
let's go with tonight f3
and what to do from here
okay we're going to play with this duo
and
I'm not gonna I'm gonna go with this
setup
J Newlin 1 2 3 4 5 thank you for the 100
bits man
all righty
okay we're putting the bishop here not
here here because I want to keep this
square up and for my queen Knight
I'm uh I'm planning on doing a little
dance
Knight f4 bishop here Knight d3 let's go
here now I'm
I'm less concerned about Bishop before
taking out my knight now because the
doubled pawns aren't really doubled now
that there's tension
I'm gonna hold off on castling
I want to get a lot of
I kind of want a maneuver quite a bit
with my minor pieces here
and well if I do this night move Bishop
here's a bit annoying
you
maybe I do want a castle you know let's
castle
you
mm-hmm well I'm gonna play rook here I
thought about this initially but now I'm
just fine if the knight drops into b4 I
feel that he would be out of play
even though it's moving forward and
throwing a punch my bishop is just as
satisfied being on b1 than he is on d3
so now not my night because he decided
to go here my knight doesn't have any he
cannot be challenged by a knight so
easily so this is desirable
the one of the key differences with this
position is that a five is a whole but
efore is not
so that said I could flush the night
away but I don't know that I want to do
that straight away because maybe I just
want to duck and then when I hit the
night he has to go backwards
I am gonna follow through with this very
idea 92 it's coming together
I'm okay with doubled pawns I think so
let's follow through
shoo
it's up Coolio
oh you know I could also have considered
something like this in fact right here
this move would force this and that's a
desirable exchange
I'm going to do it I may be mistaken
smooth might be available I don't know
okay so this is a bad bishop for good
Bishop exchange incoming I think I like
it let's do it
next step
let's take here here
prepared to give up my bishop for a
night to just destroy their Queen side
structure
hmm yeah I'm really keying in on this
square now
this bishop has a move I don't like them
start with night here to avoid this move
with the pin basically I want to play
good night versus bad bishop
let's take here okay so now definitely
this I'd have to worry about this room
so my night has just too many good
options step up my queen next
and what to do let's start with this
the C file is very important I don't
want to change the structure okay I'll
do this now now I have control over the
C file let's move forward so better
night better major pieces is now around
the time that I'm thinking about a
flight square maybe not because if the
Queen's are off I don't need this flight
square
let's welcome a queen exchange
the sending is excellent
this night I cannot speak enough of the
night
let's jump in the center he may end up
getting trapped here there's this
might just go win a pond or two
now let's do this
I don't know if it's the best conversion
it'll be good enough all right let's
just go here
now there's no quick access to the C
file and I could win the a pond
and if later black wants to exchange
rooks I'm cool with that
let's take him out while the c-file
can't be won back and here's the other
thing I have still in mind
mating ideas
they don't get to the C file I want to
keep control here let's just stop this
first off and now now we do this so if
the rook leaves the back rank we have
these ideas
could take up a very passive role
I'm fine with playing g4 let's go here
I'm trying to provoke this so I could
put them in a pin they fell for it
though
okay let's go here I could exchange
rooks and then take two versus one
no here and then these guys if he tries
to go after this he's going to be way
too slow
and from here I just want to crack open
the position so how do we do this this
seems like a good start
and then work my way and I'm gonna let
these guys simply sit simply sit
but this last move all the black pawns
are frozen
I don't want to give him up and give him
a passed pawn so I'm gonna just leave
him
prove the king
I'm trying to win upon and I'll just
take with this these guys off set these
guys off set and it's just a two versus
one
I get slow-played actually
let's just go here
you
you know upon is upon is upon
let's sneak over
you
after this guy
you
nothing to do
all right they resigned